This is part two of the Ballerina Farms discussion.
I would like to preface this video
because I know a lot of people love this account.
That if I had $10 billion,
I would live a similar life too.
I don't even take issue with the fact
that she went 12 days postpartum to do,
like a beauty pageant,
because I know women in my real life
who had to be bridesmaids
like 7 days after giving birth,
and they pulled that shit together too.
And if you wanna live this, like,
back to your roots,
conservative
Christian values lifestyle,
that's also fine.
It's when an account goes from sharing their life
to marketing their lifestyle.
I think a really good account
to show comparison of is Miriam,
who shares her life as an Orthodox Jewish woman.
Not once in my entire following of her
have I felt at all like she is selling or marketing
the Orthodox Jewish lifestyle.
But these trad wife accounts,
and I don't even think Ballerina Farm is like
the worst of
the worst of these at all.
Is there selling a lifestyle based on an ideology
that can be harmful.
And the ideology is the conservative religious,
submissive wife narrative.
And it is not an accident
that these sort of lifestyles are being glamorized
at the same historical moment
that our rights as women are being dialed back.
Because they will not be stopping
with reproductive rights.
The lifestyle that the trad wives are trying To sell
also require a husband signature
to open a bank account.
Like, there has been this huge uptick
of conservative religious ideology being pushed.
Be vigilant in what is being sold to you and why.
Because nothing happens in a vacuum,
and nothing is by accident.
And I know that sounds like conspiracy theory,
but the writings
pretty much on the wall.